[Aplausos]
muchos de nosotros cuando tenemos que
tomar una decisión pensamos que es mejor
tener la cabeza fría porque las
emociones nos quitan claridad
objetividad y nos hacen ser impulsivos
en el momento de tomar la decisión no es
cierto
pero en esta charla les voy a hablar de
por qué esta noción está equivocada hay
varios estudios de neurociencia que
indican que las emociones son muy
importantes cuando tomamos decisiones
antonio damásio su neurocientífico de la
universidad de california en los ángeles
y el estudia pacientes que justamente
tienen una lesión en el área que ven
aquí en rojo del cerebro que es la parte
orbitofrontal de la corteza prefrontal
esta área se encarga de integrar las
emociones cuando tomamos decisiones y
cuando se daña ya no somos capaces de
tomar decisiones
elliot es el caso de estudio más famoso
de antonio damásio este es el nombre que
se le dio para proteger la verdadera
identidad de este paciente
era una persona muy calificada muy
talentoso y tenía una carrera brillante
y un matrimonio muy feliz antes de que
le detectaran cáncer al cerebro cuando
les dejaron el cáncer le tuvieron que
remover justamente esta área que vemos
en rojo y después de eso él no quedó
igual conservó su inteligencia su
capacidad de percepción del lenguaje de
matemáticas se acordaba todo lo que
aprendió en el colegio y en la
universidad pero no podía tomar
decisiones
entonces en el trabajo por ejemplo podía
pasar todo el día tratando de decidir
cómo ordenar sus documentos y debía
ordenar les por fecha por relevancia por
tamaño entonces a dejar trabajos
incompletos y le terminaron despidiendo
y asimismo de lo que tenía en su vida
personal ningún problema se terminó
divorciando se volvió a casar y al poco
tiempo se volvió a divorciar agarro todo
el dinero que había ahorrado y lo
invirtió en un negocio poco viable y
quedó en la bancarrota los
neurocientíficos y los médicos estaban
perplejos porque no entendían como
alguien tan inteligente
y nadie ignorante tomaba tantas malas
decisiones una tras otra
y aquí es cuando va más yo dijo nos
estamos centrando mucho en la parte
racional y cognitiva del cerebro y
estamos dejando a un lado la parte
emocional porque es lo que notaba en las
múltiples entrevistas que tuvo con este
paciente es que no nos daba ninguna
emoción era completamente neutro incluso
cuando relataba cosas muy duras que le
habían sucedido en la vida no mostraba
emociones entonces más se le hizo un
pequeño experimento le empezó a mostrar
imágenes muy fuertes como de gente
muerta edificios en llamas y le
preguntaba el yo tú qué sientes cuando
ves de estas imágenes y el otro decía sé
que debería sentir algo pero no no
siento nada y ahí es cuando va más yo se
dio cuenta que cuando no podemos
integrar nuestras emociones a nuestra
experiencia actual
no podemos tomar decisiones
lo más desconcertante de estos pacientes
como el yo porque hay muchos otros que
tienen este mismo problema es que cuando
tienen que tomar una decisión no es que
no pueden generar opciones incluso
pueden decir de las ventajas y
desventajas de cada opción simplemente
no se pueden decidir por ninguna
los títulos preguntas a qué restaurante
te gustaría ir el viernes te pueden
decir un montón de restaurantes pero no
se pueden decidir por ninguna de esas
opciones es como que les falta ese
impulso que te da la emoción
entonces lo que dicen los estudios de
neurociencia es algo que yo corroboró
todos los días de mi consulta que es que
las emociones si son importantes cuando
tomamos decisiones solo que muchas veces
no sabemos cómo integrarlas incorporales
a nuestra toma de decisiones
les voy a hablar de los tres errores que
yo más observó en mi consulta cuando las
personas tratan de incorporar a las
emociones al proceso de tomar una
decisión
la primera muchas veces tratamos de huir
o suprimir nuestras emociones justamente
porque pensamos que nos van a ser
impulsivos pero irónicamente esto es lo
que nos lleva a ser impulsivos pues por
ejemplo digamos que estás enojado el
primer impulso que nos da es querer
alzar la voz y decir cosas hirientes
verdad
y creo que todos estamos de acuerdo que
esta no es la mejor forma de manejar una
situación o una discusión sin embargo
nuestra ira la culpable de que tomemos
esta decisión es el hecho que no la
toleramos que no la aceptamos que
queremos despojarnos de ella que
queremos desquitar esa ira la que nos
lleva
gritar o decir cosas y dientes porque
claro el rato que gritamos soltamos esa
ira ya no la sentimos a lo mejor capaz
de antiguos culpa o remordimiento pero
ira ya nos sentimos entonces
sí aprenderíamos a tolerar y aceptar la
ira a lo mejor no tuviéramos que
recurrir a ser agresivos en el momento
en que sentimos de esta emoción y al
quedarnos con la ira lo mejor podemos
empezar a explorar un poquito más que
eso que me enoja de esta situación que
me gustaría que cambie
lo mismo sucede con ansiedad por ejemplo
a mí me da mucha ansiedad la
confrontación entonces han habido muchas
ocasiones anteriormente donde yo he
tratado de evitar este tipo de
situaciones pero a la larga lo que me he
dado cuenta es que esto obviamente me
lleva a tomar malas decisiones porque
hay muchas ocasiones donde yo debería
enfrentar a este tipo de situación a
pesar de la incomodidad que me genera la
ansiedad
entonces aprendiendo a tolerar y aceptar
mi ansiedad así que yo ya no tenga que
recurrir a evitar estas situaciones para
no sentir la ansiedad lo mismo le sucede
a las personas que comen o fuman porque
están ansiosos no es la ansiedad en sí
la que les lleva a comer oa fumar sino
del hecho de que no toleran su ansiedad
que necesitan comer o fumar para no ser
y así estar tranquilos o sea es decir
a sacar la ansiedad
sí aprenderíamos a tolerar y aceptar la
ansiedad no había necesidad de comer o
fumar para no sentirla
y lo mismo sucede con las personas que
abusan sustancias
las personas dicen yo tomo para ahogar
las penas no es la pena la que te lleva
a tomar ese lecho que no la tolera
porque necesitas el alcohol para
ahogarla porque no soporta sentirla
entonces si aprenderíamos a soportar la
pena a quedarnos con ella a lo mejor no
tuviéramos que recurrir a sustancias
para ya no sentirla y evadirla
el segundo error que yo veo es que las
personas muchas veces incorporan la
emoción incorrecta cuando toman una
decisión y aquí el clásico ejemplo es
cuando tienes mucho estrés y frustración
en el trabajo y llegas a la casa y te
descritas con tu pareja o con tus hijos
nuevamente aquí es porque no nos
quedamos con emoción y no exploramos de
dónde viene que nos desquitamos con
personas que tienen poco que ver con esa
estrés y frustración que estamos
sintiendo si nos daríamos un espacio una
pausa para simplemente explorar de dónde
viene esta emoción incluso antes de
entrar por la puerta de la casa
podríamos entender que bueno estoy muy
estresada y frustrada pero eso tiene que
ver con el trabajo poco tiene que ver
con misterios queridos que estoy a punto
de ver
el tercer error que yo veo es que muchas
personas solo están pensando en la
emoción del momento y no están pensando
en las cosas que les va a dar felicidad
a la larga
por ejemplo cuando comes pastel de
chocolate y estás a dieta y gastos
dinero que no tienes estás pensando en
la alegría en euforia que te da ese
momento y no estás pensando tanto en la
culpa y el arrepentimiento que viene
después
entonces si tú exploraría tus emociones
un poquito más hacia futuro te das esa
pausa para pensarlo un poco más capaz
darías prioridad a cosas que te van a
dar felicidad más a la larga y no solo
en el momento un ejemplo más sutil de
esto digamos que tu pareja llega a la
casa un día y te dice tengo un problema
enorme en el trabajo ni sabes y a medida
que te empieza a contar tú le empiezas a
dar un montón de consejos pero notas que
no no te está escuchando del todo al
siguiente día le dices hoy amor cómo te
fue con este problema que tenías
y dice no es que ya solucione mi amigo
me dio unos consejos buenísimos y a
medida que te empieza a contar
todos los mismos consejos que tú le has
dado entonces tienes dos opciones le
puedes decir claro cuando dice tu amigo
le haces caso a mil y me escuchas o le
podrías felicitar y decir amor te
felicito qué bien qué bueno que hayas
logrado solucionar tu problema
cuántos de ustedes escogerían número 2
entonces
jajaja entonces muchos de nosotros
pensamos que la satisfacción nos va a
dar más satisfacción que nuestra pareja
reconozca que nosotros tuvimos en lo
correcto no es cierto cómo ganar esa
discusión
pero cuando hacemos esto arriesgamos que
hay una atención o una discusión no es
cierto
a la larga yo creo que nos daría más
tranquilidad y felicidad simplemente
felicitar porque sacamos muy poco de
reclamar y comenzar este momento
tensionante donde necesito que mi pareja
reconozca que yo estuve en lo correcto
entonces cuando aprendemos a no cometer
estos tres errores porque nos sentamos
con nuestras emociones y las exploramos
nos da la posibilidad
de integrarlas a nuestra mente racional
y esto es lo que nos lleva a tomar
decisiones más sabias
porque las emociones si traen
información importante acerca de
experiencias previas por ejemplo nos
dicen qué es lo que nos gusta qué es lo
que nos disgusta qué personas nos
inspiran confianza cuáles son aquellas
que nos da una sensación de desconfianza
que decimos no con esta persona no
entonces si nos damos ese espacio para
realmente escuchar nuestra mente
emocional y la integramos a la mente
racional podemos tomar decisiones
bastante sabias les doy un ejemplo
cuando escogemos nuestra carrera
si nos vamos mucho por el lado emocional
alomejor escogemos algo que nos encanta
nos fascina
va a ser difícil lucrar
por el otro lado si nos damos mucho por
el lado racional escogemos algo que
capaz nos da mucho prestigio y dinero
pero no nos encanta entonces encontrar
un balance va a ser importante escuchar
a ambos lados
en decisiones más pequeñas de la vida
diaria pasa lo mismo por ejemplo si
estás pensando en comprarte zapatos si
es que te vas mucho por el lado
emocional capaz de escoger unos zapatos
divinos
pero muy caros y prácticos si es que te
vas mucho por el lado racional en cambio
a lo mejor te compras unos zapatos
bastante prácticos pero no tan bonitos
entonces encontrar el balance nuevamente
es importante incluso en decisiones que
pensamos que son completamente
emocionales como el escoger una pareja
es importante también escuchar lado
racional porque a veces nos enamoramos
de la gente incorrecta
gente que nos hace sufrir que no nos
conviene entonces
en escuchar ambos lados es importante
ahora que entendemos que las emociones
son importantes cuando tomamos
decisiones cómo logramos escuchar más a
nuestra mente emocional
la clave aquí es la conciencia plena las
prácticas de conciencia plena nos dan el
espacio y nos dan esa pausa para
realmente explorar de dónde vienen
nuestras emociones para no incorporarlas
de forma incorrecta cuando tomamos
decisiones hacia dónde van para entender
qué son las cosas que nos va a traer más
felicidad a la larga y no solo en el
momento y también nos enseña la
aceptación para quitar esa necesidad que
tenemos de porta hnos impulsivos para
huir de nuestras emociones
ahora lo difícil de aceptar las
emociones y quedarnos con ellas en vez
de tratar de despojarlas como les decía
yo con la ira que uno trata de gritar o
decir cosas hirientes para simplemente
ya ves quitarse la ira es que es
desagradable es desagradable sentir
ansiedad o tristeza o ira muchas veces
sentimos que nos hace incluso sufrir
pero las prácticas de conciencia plena
nos enseñan que en verdad este
sufrimiento es opcional
que el sufrimiento solo viene cuando
sentimos estas emociones negativas y no
las aceptamos
porque cuando las aceptamos
incluso podemos llegar a disfrutar de
ellas por ejemplo cuántos de ustedes se
han sentado a ver una película triste y
han disfrutado de la sensación que les
da
he escuchado música nostálgica y han
sentido como que esto es hermoso
os han subido una montaña rusa o han
visto una película de terror y han
disfrutado de la sensación que les da
entonces cuando aceptamos y estamos
dispuestos a sentir estas emociones
negativas podemos llegar a disfrutar de
ellas es solo cuando sentimos ansiedad y
quisiéramos estar tranquilos o sentimos
ira o sentimos tristeza y quisiéramos
estar alegres que sufrimos
entonces
lo importante aquí es que las emociones
nos dan mucha información importante hay
que aprender a no evitarlas y evadir las
porque en verdad mientras más importante
es algo para ti más emoción te va a
hacer sentir
por ejemplo no hay cosas que te vas a
sentir más ira ansiedad tristeza alegría
amor que tu familia porque son lo más
importante
entonces si aprendes a escuchar a tu
mente emocional de una forma sabia
siempre vas a poner prioridad a lo más
importante entonces la siguiente vez que
tengan que tomar una decisión y están
pensando como que tengo que estar fuerte
imponente racional frío solo recuerden
que las emociones no son el enemigo
que en verdad si te pones un poquito
vulnerable a lo mejor vas a tomar una
decisión más empática y más juiciosa
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]